all right fake jake tapper fake news cnn
still refusing to apologize for
attacking the patriotism military
service of
an amputee veteran republican
congressman brian mast here's what fake
jake said yesterday take a look what
you're saying right now is relevant
because congressman brian mast a
republican from florida
who lost his legs by the way fighting
for democracy abroad
although i don't know what is i don't
know about his commitment to it here in
the united states
with reaction florida congressman brian
mast first of all uh
i've known you for some time now
congratulations on all your success
all that you're doing thank you so much
for all you've done for all of us
i'm i think i know you well enough you
tell me if i'm wrong
if he apologized would you accept his
apology
yeah i would accept it and i'd i'd tell
him this i'd tell him this seriously
i as i said on twitter to some degree i
lost my legs so that
you and ceo of twitter jack dorsey and
corporations said so that you could say
whatever you want
i didn't lose my legs for this so that
you can
silence whoever the hell you want and
that is a major difference
you know i i've met so many people that
have come back
from serving the american people and
protecting our liberty and freedoms
and all the challenges you have to face
and overcome and that you've done it's
beyond an inspiring story and when it
was brought up in this way i sat there
and i'm like
why would anybody do that forget about
the attacks on me they attack me
every day i you know i probably deserve
half of them anyway
but i felt it's just so fundamentally
unfair did anybody on cnn ever say
they're sorry
not that i heard of but the answer of
why
is simple you know they don't want to
get to the bottom of the questions in
these cases you've been talking about it
for the last hour
they don't want to answer those
questions they're jumping to the
conclusion
uh before they go out there and do any
fact finding and i can tell you that's
how i brought congress to silence was
saying hey
just let me ask you a quick question
here scratch my head a moment
did any of you bother to ask any of the
rioters that took siege the capitol
why they did it did you have an
interview with any of them did you bring
them before a hearing
and total silence and i'll tell you the
most uncomfortable thing for a bunch of
people that love to hear themselves talk
is silence it's the one thing they can't
take
you know brian you're an inspiring
figure for everybody and uh
you know you can you can't really ever
imagine yourself in somebody else's
shoes
i just i i am like amazed by people like
yourself
that overcome the most challenging
hardest things in life
and you know what i learned
watching you thank you for all you do